for months now we've been hearing from
Republicans about the Biden bribery
Scandal now if you're wondering David
what on Earth are you talking about what
Biden bribery Scandal that is the right
reaction because it is a Biden bribery
scandal with very little bribery no
evidence and a whistleblower no one's
been able to speak to for three years
we'll get to that in a moment but the
new development here is that our friend
Democratic Congressman Jamie Raskin has
now released the transcript of the
Ukrainian oligarch who supposedly was
involved in the bribery saying I've
never even spoken to Joe Biden this is
yet it if you're paying attention this
wouldn't be a surprise but if you were
one of the people
who has been only Loosely hearing about
Biden bribery and maybe thinking any
second now the other shoe is going to
drop and we're going to find out about
Joe Biden's crimes then you are going to
be quite surprised by this Jamie this is
HuffPost Jamie Raskin releases
transcript of Ukrainian oligarch denying
he talked to Joe Biden they did the
bribery but they never spoke barisma
co-founder mikola zlichevsky who
Republicans claim bribed Biden says in
the transcript no one from his company
ever had any contacts with Vice
President Biden that is extraordinarily
clear
as the article explains Republicans
claim there's evidence a barisma
executive apparently slashevsky Pedro
Biden a five million dollar bribe when
he was vice president in exchange for
unofficial favor they've demanded the
FBI hand over a document reflecting a
confidential sources conversation with
sligevsky Raskin has now countered with
a document of his own a three-page
transcript of a 2019 interview between
slochevsky and an acquaintance of Rudy
Giuliani who at the time was publicly
seeking dirt on Biden on behalf of then
president Donald Trump this is a quote
from slishevsky in the transcript quote
no one from burisma ever had any
contacts with Vice President Biden or
people working for him
during Hunter Biden's engagement when
asked if Vice President Biden had
assisted him or his company in any way
slashevsky says no slashevsky says no uh
in full disclosure this next paragraph
is relevant and then we'll move on to
further analysis in 2015 a barisma
executive named Vadim pasharsky thanked
Hunter Biden in an email for having the
chance to meet Joe Biden at a Charity
Dinner other guests told the New York
Times They don't recall Joe Biden having
any substantive conversation with
pasharsky it was a handshake by all of
the evidence that we have so think about
the multiple layers here now if I came
to some of these conspiracy theorists
and said okay
the guy from barisma says he never met
Biden they could say well the bribes
happen through intermediaries even if
you didn't meet Biden people working for
you could have met with people working
for Joe Biden okay hypothetically that's
possible number one we have no evidence
of that and more importantly number two
the claim here from slushefsky in the
transcript is very clear no one at
barisma not just slashevsky no one at
barisma has had contact with anyone
working for Joe Biden so this rules out
it precludes the possibility of this it
was intermediaries now I think it is
important to remember that every aspect
of this story has fallen apart it's also
important to remember
that if Jamie Raskin had access to this
transcript Republicans also did because
this was a transcript related to I
believe it was the impeachment of trump
one of the impeachments of trump so not
only have Republicans like James Comer
and others been insisting that this is a
thing absent evidence
Republicans if we understand this
correctly had access to the ex this
exact same transcript dating all the way
back to at least a few years and yet
they continued to make claims like this
claim uh oh I'm sorry they continued to
make claims that they have evidence of
bribery but when they were questioned
about it they said things like the
following here is James Comer admitting
we don't even know if these supposed
tapes that we have proving Biden bribery
are legitimate when will you be able to
confirm if these recordings are legit
never is that gonna take well I can
confirm that the recordings were in the
1023 remember I was with Senator
Grassley when we saw the unredacted
version okay so because Grassley was
saying alleged yesterday so these
recordings are legit you can confirm
they are legitimate they were I can
confirm they were listed in the 1023
that the FBI redacted we don't know if
they're legit or not but we know that
the foreign National claims he has them
there you go so this was like one of the
first of a thousand signals that this
may not really be what some of these
Republicans are claiming that it is we
have alleged tapes from a purported
whistleblower
flaming okay we're like three layers
removed already and we actually have
very very little here is James Comer
being interviewed by Sean Hannity these
this is not new material this is just
kind of painting the picture for you
about why we shouldn't be surprised that
this is evaporating before our very eyes
like when you pour water on cotton candy
and it just becomes nothing uh here is
James Comer saying well yeah The
Whistleblower with the tapes we also
kind of like haven't spoken to The
Whistleblower in three years with
respect to the tapes look it mentioned
in the FBI form that the oligarch had 17
tapes of Biden two with Joe Biden
accepted the broad that he used that as
an answer this is a high-ranking was a
high-ranking member uh or owner of
barisma
yes that is exactly right so have you
had anything can you show them
unfortunately nobody's had any contact
with him for the last three years you
know the MSNBC makes fun of me when I
said that there are a lot of people that
were involved in uh the Biden
shenanigans that that are are currently
missing but with respect to this guys
why will you not jail Biden on the basis
of alleged tapes we don't have from a
whistleblower no one's found for three
years isn't that enough to imprison
Biden for life so again if you've been
following this show for a while uh we
have not been ignoring the Biden bribery
story we've been covering the Biden
bribery story for what it is which is a
series of unfounded allegations with
evidence they don't have from
whistleblowers they can't reach and now
the latest is hey we have a transcript
from 2019 where the guy who supposedly
is going to blow the blow the roof off
of this thing actually says I haven't
spoken to Biden my staff hasn't spoke
talking to Biden my staff hasn't spoken
to any of Biden's staff there is just
nothing here Joe Biden committed a crime
investigate prosecute jail him if that's
what the law says I'm not going to stand
in the way but right now it is all like
wet cotton candy leaving crumbs
evaporating before our very eyes whether
you're a carpenter painter or just want
to be prepared for emergencies if you
need a gas mask or respirator go to our
sponsor parcel safety as many of you
know I'm into emergency preparedness not
crazy prepping but I want to have some
food stored some supplies I've talked
about water and multiple respirators are
part of that because it's just a staple
of being prepared respirator sales have
been way up in recent years natural
disasters wildfires polluted air
chemical plant accidents unrest of
different kinds militarized police all
sorts of different reasons you you never
know when a respirator or a gas mask
from parcel safety might come in handy
and it could be when you least expect it
parcel safety respirators are also
perfect for professionals contractors
painters people doing DIY projects at
home all of parcel safety's respirators
come with a one-year manufacturer's
warranty every respirator or gas mask
comes with a filter competitive prices
large discounts for organizations and
outstanding customer service to be
totally honest I've said before I'm
using these for changing baby diapers
people think I'm kidding and then they
come visit me and I really am not it it
actually is very useful to other parents
out there I do recommend it go to
davidpackman.com safety use the code
Pacman for 25 off your first order the
link is down below